Okay guys, this is a concept question we're being asked this time.
So which of the following statements is true about the poor pressure in the following soil
sample during each case?
For case A, we can see is sand fill with saturated soil beneath the groundwater level.
Case B is sand fill where the soil is dry.
And case C is where the sand fill has saturated soil and is above the groundwater level.
And we can choose between any of these combinations that we see here.
Now the answer to this question is A. And the reason for that is depicted here in the
image, which you can see at this following link if you want more information.
But essentially in dry soil, the poor pressure is going to be zero, which is our case
B. Above the groundwater table where the soil is still saturated, the poor pressure is going
to be negative, which is our case C. And below the groundwater table, poor pressure is going
to be positive, which is our case A. So in this case, it's correct to say that case A positive
is greater than case B, zero, is greater than case C, negative.
And that's it.
This is just a question about poor pressure.
You'd have to know some geotechnical theory to get this one right.
I'm not sure there's much in the manual that's going to help you, but that's just
how some concept questions go.